If this is the position, we see that position
always increases with time.
There is no way that the derivative can be negative,
that the rate of change can be negative.
Otherwise, the position would have to go down
if that was the case, so we can rule out the red version.
Now let's look at this step, almost a step.
We need to ramp up the velocity
and ramp down the velocity.
Here, we accelerate, and here, we decelerate.
Okay. And this is an almost precise replica of that one,
so the same shape--it has to be the green one.
It cannot be the purple one.
Now for this curve,
we accelerate positively
The velocity grows.
You see that we start with small velocity.
The velocity gets larger as we go
up to that point here.
So acceleration has to be positive.
The rate of change of velocity has to be positive,
which rules out the green curve.
We are left with deciding whether
the red curve is the right one or
the purple curve is the right one.
Look at this part of the curve.
The position is decreasing.
If position is decreasing,
velocity has to be negative.
See, we start with a velocity of almost 0,
and then the velocity becomes very negative.
This is very steep.
The rate of change is very high in a negative direction,
which means that we need acceleration to the
negative--strong negative acceleration.
It has to be this red part.
It can't be that green part.
And here, acceleration is positive again--
--high and positive--
to turn that negative velocity
into a velocity of 0.
We got a positive peak in the acceleration.
And eventually, the acceleration is 0, the velocity is 0,
and the rate of change of the position is 0, so it's the red curve.